what would happen if a young man came to
his parents
his dad in particular said you know what
i've joined this group isis
so this is what happens when you tell
your dad you joined isis
[Music]
now you know this is a way of life this
way of life that we should
try to put out there for everyone to see
help you understand islam and muslims
maybe you've been duped you've been
watching the mainstream media and much
of the information out there
you've got half truths truths all types
of things
and you come and you really want to know
through all the confusion so
we're going to be in this episode we
have a special guest he's the author of
holy wars
crusades and jihad
he's with us to cover this very
important topic and we're gonna
when we come back we're gonna find out
what happens what would happen if a
young man
came to his parents his dad in
particular said you know what i've
joined this group
isis well we got a real live example for
you and we're gonna have a breakdown of
it a reaction
to that and we'll break it down from
there we'll be right back don't go
anywhere
assalamu alaikum welcome back to the
dean show now before we go
into our reaction video
where a son is gonna approach his father
and you get to see what actually happens
when he brings information to his dad
that he's joined
isis let's see the muslim response to
that for my next guest here
sheikh jalal how are you good to have
you with us
it's been years but not only are you the
author of 50 concepts brought by prophet
muhammad peace and blessed be upon him
the author of muhammad's role in islam
also holy wars crusades in jihad
you've also translated half of the quran
into
i'm sorry half of the tafsir of the
quran by ibn kathir
uh may allah be pleased with him into uh
english
is that correct yes yeah so you've
gotten your hands pretty big you've been
pretty busy there i'm working on
translating tafsir sadi now which is
a very good book for newcomers for
dawai because it it doesn't go in the
depth when kathir goes
yes too so it is really a very good
inshallah we have two volumes out
uh eight more to come inshallah so you
you've been uh
you've been busy all these years you've
been involved in the dawah helping
educate people there's a lot of
misconceptions about islam
absolutely it's been 26 years and i
started translating authoring books
alhamdulillah so far close to 60. yeah
in the past
18 years i dedicated more effort towards
misconceptions about islam about topics
of jihad extremism
hawari all kinds of things that are
current for today's
uh you know contemporary generation of
human beings
we're going to we're going to get in
we're going to get into this video and
then get your reaction
our reaction after we watch it how's
that
go ahead all right what's up guys it's
me lakas my dad's upstairs
when he comes down i'm about to pull the
craziest prank
on my dad i have tattoos so imma tell
him it's a symbol of isis
my heart literally racing at the moment
i'm so scared
but i'm doing it just for you guys
so i guess he's trying he's uh faking
his dad out right
australian
so he's about to tell him he joined isis
huh
so this is what happens when you tell
your dad you join
all right so i know this was uh this was
kind of like he's uh we won't get into
it should he be pranking his dad or
whatnot
but i i wanted to show this because uh
many you know
of our brothers in humanity you know
those peop you know the not yet muslims
who are out there
they kind of associate you know with the
mainstream media
that uh you know this is kind of
correlates with islam isis the insane
state
but we got this is pretty much a good
example of what someone could expect
if they came to the you know the to the
average uh father mother he just got up
he's we just showed one smack but you
know this was
real reaction from the father he's about
to get a beat down what do you what's
your reaction to that
first of all i like the father i hope to
meet him i like him very much
and what he said for the tattoo first
tells me that this father has been
keeping up with islamic information
because it is not allowed
for you to change your body with a
tattoo or anything that's permanent this
is
a trust from allah the creator
you should keep it in the best shape you
can health wise
and your skin and don't do any damage to
it because you'll be asked about it
also oh that's a good point so we can
even derive because that's another thing
that many people are just kind of like
you know jumping into our tattoos
so you just uh have been established in
islam as being haram from the beginning
because this is changing of allah's
creation look how beautiful your skin is
why would you tarnish it with something
that maybe tomorrow you'll wake up in
the morning and say this is stupid
yeah i don't like the symbol maybe i
can't change it you know
it's very tough so this is number one
the reaction this man had for his
son is incredible
and i think most muslims would do the
same
except those who are not well acquainted
with the religion or they have a lot of
anger
against what's happening against muslims
so they don't care what the religion
says
maybe they will suggest to their
children because i know people who
suggested
to their boys to join isis
and they went along with them too but
these are such a small minority among
muslims
that i can't believe uh
that most uh fathers would agree
i'll give you another example maybe the
father is angry also
against what's happening to muslims and
if he
thinks that somebody from the street
went and joined them
it's not going to matter to him if his
son does it that's a different case
so people usually who are from uh who
agree with this kind of violence
it doesn't matter if somebody else do it
did it
but if it comes to their family they
would not allow it
because they know it's wrong so this
this brother masha allah
the father i i love what how he did it
not the smacking part but
uh it's it's really important for us to
understand this is the typical
muslim family period there you go that
this is a typical
muslim family and and typical responses
a young man is probably gonna get from
his family uh you know really
you know uh bad reaction you know not a
happy one because some people think like
okay
you know and it's these things are just
so ridiculous but you gotta
you gotta sometimes you know address it
and sometimes hopefully people will you
know snap out of it because
many people get hypnotized by much of
the the false propaganda that's out
there
but i like what you said the the father
was saying you know he was even saying i
believe
um yeah he was saying they're not muslim
he was saying a bunch of things
uh and no about the tattoo first he said
synthetic okay first with the tattoo
yeah how about if someone says look uh
what about henna
it's not permanent what about that if
let's say if you give him a substitute
if you want you know put something on
and not a tattoo because
wouldn't that be something equated to
like henna first of all is
for women okay oh
man yeah don't take the woo out
leave it there secondly they have to
remove it every time they want to renew
that will do ablution for salah so it's
a big hassle
yeah yeah see there is there is some
kind of
uh henna now that actually doesn't make
a film
on top of your skin so it allows the
water to go in
yes that's different but henna is for
women
and also you know they shouldn't be
showing it
out when they have it in their hands
they should wear gloves if they go out
you know other men could see them
so there are restrictions to that but
hannah is fine it's okay
and then what was the other thing now
then so he he caught the father caught
that
the father said for the tattoo he said
that's you know that's a
isn't it yeah i love this father yeah i
like him very much
uh-huh and then and i don't like the way
the son
made it like this you know oh the way he
faked his father because his father i'm
sure he would have felt
maybe could have a heart attack very bad
yeah very bad yeah yeah
but um so we we don't agree with that
but
we can take a lesson here for the
general public to see like you said
typical
typical uh household you know
uh muslim household and the sun faces
there but it's a real reaction
to what would happen you know if someone
said that they joined this
insane state tell us about this insane
state
what what can you in your book that you
actually um you have a second addition
to this
that uh it's not in print print yet
right no it's not can you tell us what
kind of points you
discuss about this group um now the
first edition of the jihad book i
wrote it after 9 11
it's been printed in the states and i
actually we gave hundreds of copies to
security agencies government agencies
public libraries because i want the
people to know what jihad
says what jihad is really in islam
and in that book i made a comparison
between
rules of warfare between the old
testament the new testament and the
quran and sunnah
yeah now since then
that was the first edition since then
you have new things that happened you
know the
afghanistan you know the qaeda were
completely
eradicated for at some point and then
osama bin laden being killed
and the appearance of isis isis is
one of the most extreme cases of
khawarij
that i have seen and that's a lot to say
now the khawaris concept is something
that
islam has installed in their hearts
because the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
he foretold about these groups
that killed muslims that defy
the islamic law and the defiance of
islamic law meaning
so that's why they're called khawarit
according to ebitemia one of the major
scholars of islam of all time
he said the khawarij rebelled against
islamic law
that's why they are called now what do
the hawaii do
it's the same isis like al-qaeda and
other people
their main point is those who don't
don't agree with us
specifically and especially muslims are
not muslims
that's why they target them the most of
the violence that's been happening
is against muslims that's an important
point many people don't know that that
that this uh um group the daesh can you
call them
islamic iraq iraq and syria
is syria lebanon jordan and palestine so
that would translate to daish yes
how about the insane state i've heard
also this have you heard this
instead of i don't call them insane they
know what they're doing okay
um the hawari ideas have been plaguing
muslim communities
since the time of the companions of
muhammad sallallahu islam in fact they
killed three
of the successors of prophet muhammad
they killed three of them one
some muslims agree that they are the
best
men of all time yeah after the prophets
and the messengers allah sent
so until today we're having problems
every generation has
its own plague with al-qaeda now
sorry now al-qaeda itself
that's funny you see they became very
popular they had lots of money
especially before they did what they did
in uh america here in 911
which caused them to lose a country they
were they had in their pocket
this is this this could be insane called
insane
because you had the whole country to
yourself why would you go and attack
another country
so you and you know that retaliation
will come then you lose everything and
you hide in caves like
brats i'm sorry to say now they never
called themselves islamic state
you see this group now
that is in total disagreement and
their enemies of the qaeda and other
khawaris groups they distinguish
themselves by calling them the islamic
state and by doing so they committed so
many sins
number one they're even more extreme
than the people before them
because from history khawaris
quickly split into groups who attack
each other and call each other
non-muslims remember
then the newest one will be harsher than
the one before
and more violent the things that these
people did
like burning people in in acid or
covering them
in mud or in dirt until the neck and
then
letting dogs eat them or whatever this
is so insane brother
the action but they know what they're
doing so isis
the the biggest sin i've seen i i
consider is
they brought the islamic state the
khilafah
into their behavior which is un-islamic
at the core
this what makes me angry now they made
people make fun of islam
of muhammad salla of the jihad anything
that's good in our religion
anything that people think isn't good
and they're wrong
all the time they brought the name of
islam into all of this now the islamic
muslims want the khilafah back not this
way
that's why i have never considered them
in any way form to be a legitimate
islamic authority they're just thieves
and murderers and rapists
look what they do to the what they did
to the christian communities in iraq i
i need you to ask me about that ask me
yeah that that's what i was going to get
to
tell me so that's one point that they
actually kill
more muslims than anyone else is that
true
absolutely look look at iraq after the
american invasion
which absolutely was a disaster caused
the death of a million muslims
and iraq never attacked america before
it had nothing to do with al-qaeda or
911 or any of that nonsense so they
destroyed saddam's regime and now people
you know split into so so many groups uh
tens of groups fighting each other
including shia tenzi fighting each other
you know who is fighting who for what
reason yeah
so in iraq what happened is that
uh if you think about the numbers
now after 9 11 i mean after the
occupation of iraq until now almost a
million muslims died
how many american soldiers almost
so you talk about the deaths in in iraq
about four thousand
five thousand it's not even five
thousand i know they hide the numbers
sometimes which is about five thousand
maximum
compared to a million muslims and much
of that
violence is from muslim groups against
each other
abu musab zarqawi and his group they
were killing people
right and left and so if you compare the
numbers
put how many people were killed by the
so-called coalition
mainly christian countries of course and
who were killed in iraq by muslims
you'll find a significant part
of that is from the hawari group the
qaeda and then isis
and it's muslims look at the numbers
that's all that i'm asking look at the
casualties of american soldiers in iraq
since they attacked iraq and occupied it
as compared to how many muslims have
been killed there they didn't
kill all of them americans they didn't
kill even a hundred thousand
i don't think they even killed that
fifty thousand they opened the door to
all this
death and destruction by bringing down
saddam hussein
one of the most terrible tyrants that
muslims have ever had to deal with
but when they brought him down the
country split into so many groups
fighting each other so
in syria who are they attacking there
aren't
american soldiers there russians came
later
so who in the in the year since they
went into syria until now
who are the victims muslims
yeah now you mentioned you mentioned the
christians
there that were there it was the yazidis
who was this group the yazidis or people
that i don't know
yazidis they're confusing basically it's
a religion
that combines many other religions
christianity judaism
idol worship whatever it is it's just i
don't think the people themselves
can distinguish that this idea came from
here this idea came from there it's just
a collection of things
now i had a debate once with one of
those evangelicals who attack islam
so their point is look at the violence
of islam their
killing exterminating the christians in
iraq and of course in syria i said
uh yeah it seems terrible what happened
to them
how long you said they've been living
there they said they were there before
islam came
i said what islam indoctrinates
the extermination of christians and jews
and islamic countries or under muslim
control how come they're still living
here
until isis attacked them all these
centuries
they've been living there in peace the
yazidis they've yeah so if islam says
kill them
they were there before islam came and
they remained
in peace and prospering until isis came
so why would you bring the name islam in
it when islam ruled that area
for 1300 years and nothing of that kind
happened to the christians
this is this proves that islam does not
allow
violence against peaceful christian
populations
yeah you see the point here so he's
saying islam
is the reason behind the isis attacking
the christians
i said they've been there before islam
how come they lived until today
if islam calls for that the muslims from
the early era could have exterminated
them
right but all these centuries nothing
happened to them
the fact that they're still living there
is in fact
perfect proof that islam doesn't allow
this kind of violence because they
they left them live man this is you know
what i'm saying
the word that isis started against
muslims mainly
who just believe in in their ideology
and
claiming to fight non-muslims this war
has made the people who
want to join isis the young people
uh been attracted to the war for a few
reasons if they live in here they can't
take a gun and shoot people
okay there they can shoot anyone they
like muslims specifically
here they can't rob a bank and use it
to buy slaves slave girls
belonging to peaceful communities that
prospered
under islam for more than 13 centuries
14 centuries
but there they can go and buy these
women and they consider this as
a legitimate captured during war
men and women you see yeah so they call
them slave girls
i call it zina what zina means
is that it is rape and they should be
stoned for it
see what they're doing is completely out
of uh
islam in so many ways but the biggest
problem and
crime is the ideology ideology of i
explained the ideology of hawari here by
the way
in the second edition of the jihad book
that's coming
i'm having more even evidence tens of
hadith from the prophet of allah
explain the khawarij by name by action
by ideology by
and also by faith you know there is a
hadith
a statement from rasulullah where he
said
are the dogs of hell fire how can islam
be responsible for this group what they
do today
when the prophet of islam says this is
this is our these are his their ideas
this is the way they go about
doing or practicing the ideas and
they're going to hell fire
so this is uh you can say that this is a
clear prophecy then
absolutely right absolutely so this
would also go back to you can
you can also equate this with uh as is
being a prophecy
proof of prophet muhammad as other
prophecies but
to add to the proof of him being the
last and final messenger sent to mankind
with the difference being
he said tens of statements about these
people other prophecies maybe one
statement
one incident so this one because of the
danger of these people
he had multiple problems absolutely
because it is a revelation from allah
what he says
yes so when he said it he spoke about
this group
has been some of the most dangerous
groups for muslims
they kill muslims that's what he says
they kill muslims they don't spare
anybody who is fearful of allah someone
who is a good believer they don't spare
them
they lie they deceive they do everything
today
that islam prohibits under the name of
islam i mean is there any
any islamic law that uh uh things that
are not allowed for muslims that they
didn't do man every day you hear a new
thing that islam forbids
you can't do that you know that uh pilot
if jordan pilot that they uh captured
madel
okay that guy was his plane was shut
down
so they they burned him alive
i had a meeting with one of the security
agents in jordan and he was asking me
about i said
listen burning anybody alive is not
allowed because the prophet of allah
muhammad himself
no one burns with fire except the
creator of the fire
so only allah takes people to hell fire
we can't do that now
he says whatever i said i don't need to
denounce it because
burning somebody like this is absolutely
unacceptable however they are put you
know
lowering people into acid containers
dogs snakes so it seems like
somebody who has been stoned from the
minute they were born
until today who claimed to be muslim
they're sitting
in a office somewhere what should i do
now to people that's
so outrageous you know and they don't
care what islam says so
the point i want to mention here the
biggest
theme that those khawari always had from
the beginning
until today we want to bring back
ruling by what allah has revealed
they are the biggest group who actually
destroys
what allah has revealed never ruled by
what allah has revealed nothing
so they are their danger now made
rasulullah say so many statements about
them
his companions had the opportunity to
kill to
to to fight the first hawari groups
and they killed off man the third khalif
khalifa islamic state khilafah their
ancestors
and then the prophet's cousin they
killed him
and in every generation they come up uh
one last point
the hadith also warn muslim
muslims that these groups will keep
coming in every generation
maybe you didn't hear that but that's
why we've been plagued throughout our
history with this group
they keep coming and the one that's
before them may be
completely destroyed the new ones will
say oh these people were stupid they
didn't know what to do
you know with the smarter ones and they
become more violent
he i can't believe there is nothing that
these people
which is haram in islam disallowed that
they didn't do
it's unbelievable so to attach islamic
state to it
what's wrong with you people islamic
state islamic state allowed you to go to
peaceful christian communities they've
been living before muhammad came
and prospered after muhammad came stayed
alive in their areas until
just a few years back you go and kill
them and steal their women and call them
your slave girls
no they're not so this is all of these
things we're seeing this is pretty much
opposite of islam and this is
this has nothing to do with islam that's
that's clear
correct i this is a perfect statement
you just said but
don't fail to mention that islam doesn't
allow it
islam doesn't islam identified this
group by name
and by action and by creed yeah so it's
not only islam doesn't allow it
islam already told us about these people
tell me some people have have
brought to light that many of the
members of this
ideology this group that because you had
during saddam hussein's
era you had was it called the bath house
right yeah so when they got dismantled
many of them who were seculars many who
didn't even believe in god
they actually were behind some of the
formation of this group have you heard
this yeah that's true
is that true yeah but the actions of
isis
are identical to the actions of al-qaeda
are under kind of
identical to the actions of the khawaris
before them and before them all the ways
from the beginning
so the fact that some of the people
today even shia would join isis just to
tarnish
islam and the sunni islam it's a fact
but that that's irrelevant yeah why
because throughout their history they've
been consistent
so the fact that today we have some
people
look at their ideology at their past
their actions
their statements their behavior and
you'll find this consistent with
al-qaeda and every other group that
started during the time of muhammad yeah
maybe he didn't hear that did i i think
i told you this last time because
the first guy the ancestor who will be
answering for all the
sins of those people he came to prophet
muhammed objected
to muhammad salla calling him o muhammad
or messenger of allah you have not been
fair
look he believes he is the messenger of
allah who receives revelation
allah is directing him to say and do
whatever he did this is one incident
during the time of the prophet
now that this this person the prophet
was giving out money
money and then he actually had the
audacity to say
you're not being fair i imam
he said this guy the contradictions he
had
from the beginning muhammad rasulullah
not fair if you believe he is muhammad
rasool allah
you have to believe his faith he's the
epitome of fairness
so the response from rasulullah
was can be read two ways he said
woe to you who can be fair if i'm not
fair
woe to you if i'm not fear who's going
to be fair yeah
i have earned failure
and misery if i am not fair
why because i am the messenger of allah
if i can't act
fairly then i have i'm a loser
in another narration
the first one is about himself the
second one you can read it
you have end loss and failure if i'm not
fear
ibn said if you believe i am the
messenger of allah
and yet i can't be fair then you are a
failure and a loser
this is the khawarij so rasulullah said
to his people
from the descendant descendants of this
man and people like him
they will come this group and then he
started mentioning the khawali you see
here so the the issue is all about money
uh do you need to take a break or
something keep it going
all the issue of the hawaii is about
money so their ancestors
he comes to rasulullah objecting to the
way rasulullah divided
the war spoils of hernan a battle
so it was bad money okay now rasulullah
said from this man
people will come who say this do this
and he described their ideology and
practices
as if he's living with us today yeah
this is how clear those descriptions are
then they come every time and rebel
against muslim leaders
and against uh muslim communities
and it's all about money i says isis
is consistent so they go to tadmur
al-maira
al-mera in syria has lots of ruins
so they dig up those ruins find golden
stuff
they take it to europe to sell the the
idol staff and the things that are you
know
that could be sell the artifacts could
be sold if they're small
yes you know they can actually put them
in a bag and take them to europe
they did that the big ones they brought
the media to show them we are
shooting down yeah these big idols can
you imagine it's all about money man
has nothing to do with islamic state or
ruling
but we'll see the i mean many
intelligent people you know people who
are sincere genuine
they know that people who have looked
into it they've investigated they know
that because
on one end this is what islam says the
whole muslim world has condemned them
this is actually kind of would you say
unified many of the muslims who have
come together
but then what is the agenda on the other
side you said money here
seems like money is the agenda here when
you have the islamophobes and
uh the haters of islam who are also now
capitalizing because i think
when the when the uh the numbers come in
i think it was from 15
let's say to 30 the cia had calculated
how many actually went to join this
french element and it came out to like
zero point zero zero
you know one nine for something like
that some very very like speck of a
number
compared to what we have over one point
how many six seven
billion muslims all over the globe
but what do you what do you say that um
so that's the reality the fact this is a
fringe element very small you know
the same way we don't equate you know
kkk to christianity and
and uh and they say hey we believe in
love jesus right
right and they're christians the prince
of peace yeah
so uh shooting muslims yeah right and
left
so what what what what what what do you
i mean for for the other side
who are constantly you know using this
as ammunition
who you know to to try to uh paint the
picture
what do you think their agenda is this
is just business
an excellent question uh as as many
questions as
as received i i received about this
topic this is the first time
somebody says it directly
the other side you know people said
uh bush went to went into iraq for the
oil
yes he did but he also went for
christianity then president bush
reportedly having claimed that god told
him to go to war
newly released memo showing that mr
bush's defense secretary
having placed on the cover of his daily
reports to the president
biblical passages and corresponding war
imagery
that carefully framed the mission in
iraq as nothing less than a christian
crusade
what another faith might call a jihad
he went in for oppression of muslims to
control muslims he went for
there isn't he stated this also he said
that the lord told him god
the father told him he said something
like this i heard you and then one of my
lectures i said he was deceived
his cousin the devil told him allah
didn't tell him to go kill a million
muslims
that's for sure but anyway so it's a
complex
uh reason uh or type of reasons or
collection of reasons on the other side
it's not only to tarnish islam they want
to bring islam down completely and this
started from
the first day it continued all the way
until today
they see islam as the biggest threat
islam had the 600 year
i mean christianity had a 600 year
advance notice
they came to this life 600 years before
islam yet islam now is the
largest religion on earth throughout
their history they know the danger comes
from
it's about hatred for islam wanting to
stop islam
also the muslims who are practicing the
religion they're also their enemies
they want to exterminate them they want
to have them killed
muslim countries they want them to be
always involved in warfare and violence
and so that they never stand up and
become a unified country
so they can you know fend for themselves
at least
so and the money the money is
always in the eyes and hearts
of those non-muslim communities
such as hindus christians who fight
against islam so money is there as a
primary
but it's not a primary reason for them
doing what
but it's not the only one yeah now you
have uh you mentioned
islam coming 600 years afterwards
how do you def how do you differentiate
would it be islam with a
with a big eye like when we say because
usually we'll say islam was there from
the beginning submission to the will of
the creator not the creation
we'll say that jesus did islam he
submitted his will to god to allah
moses so how do you make that difference
it's very easy uh
judaism is not islam and christianity is
not islam
so if we're talking about isa his
original did he do islam
absolutely okay he was a muslim prophet
he called to islam
he told his people i i'm only a slave of
allah
the old the new testament says and i
quoted this in the second jihad book two
and the first one
he says when they run the people who
kept invoking his name in this life oh
jesus help us thank you jesus
they don't thank allah the creator they
thank jesus he says
uh jesus said you will come to me on
that day
to say that we used to invoke your name
you know and this and that
he said get away from me or people who
do iniquity
i don't know you so people who invoke
him as a god a creator
jesus said to them in the new testament
on the day of judgment until you get
away from me you know iniquity what it
means in arabic
iniquity is pretty much
associating others in the worship of
allah
that's what the muslims say that jesus
told them
i am a slave of allah i am not a creator
of one third of a creator or one
in a personality of creators i am a
human being
so if you worship jesus it's shirk
associating others with allah islam came
with the same thing that jesus told them
and taught them and musa before him
moses and abraham
but they invoke his name as a god as a
creator they thank him they worship him
they pray to him they consider him one
third of uh
uh whatever a part of the trinity he
told them
on the day of judgment when you come to
me i'm gonna tell the to tell you get
away from me
you're committing shirk
you see how how significant this this
word is
yes in english when i found it in
english i i shook it
because absolutely synonymous same thing
absolutely yeah and he was saying it
means you've been unjust
yeah god created you gave you everything
you have your entire life existence
everything this is important this is
very important here so the creator gave
you everything but now you give
somebody else yeah uh but people get
people get
a little bit um surprise when you say
jesus was muslim now we know when you
define it it makes sense that because
a muslim is one who has submitted
themselves to the will of the creator
correct and islam is submission to the
will of the creator that's in action
but now someone says how when now how
was he a muslim when that word didn't
even exist
that's we're not talking about uh the
the the word itself the concept now
the concept of it being a muslim a
prophet of islam
means uh all what the islamic religion
has to bring
uh very important number one is the
creed
every prophet who came including jesus
and i proved it in the second jihad and
first jihad book
that jesus actually said it in your book
uh yeah holy wars yeah
crucifixion he called to monotheism yeah
that he is the creator
i am i am a slave i only do what he
tells me to do
he never said worship me or created you
in anywhere from
so isa he came with allah
there is no deity worthy of worship
except allah and that allah is one
you see because when they asked him what
is the first commandment
isa the jews he said the first
commandment
here you uh oh you israel your lord
god is one lord period absolutely
this is allah see
yeah is the core of our existence allah
created us so that we know him by his
names and attributes
he's the only creator and he's the only
one who deserves to be worshipped
now you being a scholar in islam and
also you know knowing the
the original language of the quran was
revealed in
can you tell us because you've used the
word allah you obviously you know the
arabic language very well when you open
up a christian bible
the word allah is it there in the
christian bible
17 times the word allah is using just
the first chapter
of genesis is it yeah i mean
that that ask me where ask me how
where how first of all you know i mean
this is very powerful because uh on one
one point people are saying this is some
totally you know a different god
but jews and christians this is a very
like important point
you will separate the jews and
christians the jews what's the name of
the creator
in the old testament hello elohim
so you remember that craig wynn who
attacked islam once and said islam
prophet of mercy is the prophet of doom
violence whatever
so he says allah is a fake name
i had a chapter and i don't need to
explain more i said
elohim allah god
which one doesn't which one doesn't
belong yeah see god is not the name
break it break it down again you said
elohim
elohim god which one doesn't
belong they brought up this name
uh in the 15th century yeah when they
translated
the uh bible into uh the german
languages and other languages they
brought the name
god in my first and second jihad book i
proved that the etymology of god
it means an idol an idol
but now you're saying our tradition is
judeo-christian
there they believe in the old testament
bill the old testament has never said
the word god jesus has never said the
word god he said allah
elohim i i found in encyclopedia
britannica
when you when they trace it back to the
language that he spoke aramaic
many have found that he said allah have
you heard this
to me this is even closer than no no at
the
end yeah it's true for respect
so that's for respect in the arabic
language but you know masha allah
you have a good brain and i ask allah
that we have so many like your brother
you're doing so much for islam elohim
allah god
why would you come and say allah doesn't
belong god does what's wrong with you
man
so that's what you told him so the 15th
century until now they use the word god
but the original bible doesn't have it
the paul has never said god
in any way or form including when he was
writing in the european languages
okay he never said god what did he bring
from no what about they say no he said
jehovah
yahuwah yahuwah is one
way of saying allah by rearranging the
word
according to the community you lived in
the language there how they
addressed allah still you have the alif
and
the alam and the ha in it so jehovah
they call him his yahuwah he is allah
that's that's
that's allah also yeah yeah yeah so we
don't have no objection to that
absolutely not now how do you connect it
again
elohim which is in the hebrew bible and
the old
uh new testament books before the 15th
century
elohim
but the jehovah part how did you explain
that again for people because
the letters that confirmed you know
is one way of saying allah to ill
abu bakr actually this is a hebrew word
yeah abu bakr
once uh had something that is the
companion of the problem yeah
yeah he's the successor of rasulullah
muslims considering the best man
ever after muhammad salla and he is his
sex khalifa
not isis khalifa is the original good
khalifa
once he heard the statement he didn't
like he said by allah
this statement did not come from an ill
means diet the deity see
it means deity now the hebrews used
elohim muslims use allah
allah whatever so when you hear
yahuwah it has the same
foundation that comes to my ear that it
confirms what the hebrews
and the arabs used to call allah the
creator and this includes
islam this is very powerful because you
have a whole people
stuck without the true name of god so
people are saying
god they don't even many people don't
even say jehovah they don't they say
they equate jesus they put him in there
and they say the father
uh what i often tell people are
christian friends out there
i often and what do you think about this
i'll tell them look the lord's prayer
it's very powerful it says oh our father
who art in heaven
if you just say how you know ab rabb
is father rabb is lord do they
when they call on god they say the
father we don't call him father but we
will say this is allah this is
this is the creator and if they stick to
this prayer
only praying because jesus is not in
this prayer and then it says oh
your will be done not anyone else says
this is islam
this is a great place for people to
start for seeking guidance isn't it what
do you think
i think you're hitting it there yeah
listen let me uh complete the thought
about arisa being
a prophet of islam he called the same
monotheism
monotheism monotheistic ideology that
muhammad called to musa moses called to
abraham noah everybody
so all the prophets came consistently
with the same
faith now they didn't call it islam
during the time of isa maybe they did we
don't know there is so much
of that history we don't know exactly
what exactly he said or didn't say yeah
but the faith is the same and i proved
it
in holy wars crusades jihad edition
number one
number two i proved it from the bible
yeah so now
they're there they mention the creator
they say the word father
islam doesn't object to describing allah
as being the father if the meaning is
the one who takes care of his people
we are allah's creation he promised he's
going to take care of us
like a father takes care of his family
so in that context
it's fine okay why muslims now object to
using it describing allah because the
christians
meant it literally that's the problem
now
now saying that he had a literal son and
he was the literal father
but you're explaining it where like a
father who takes care
you should read you know my website
islamlife.com
was hacked and i have
i have proof that evangelicals actually
hacked my website uh it's gonna come
back soon insha'allah islam life.com
i-s-l-a-m-l-i-f-e
dot com i had an article there about
the christians they came up with the
concept of
uh of course the father
the son and the holy ghost the holy
ghost they mean jibril
islam the angel now the catholics who
are and the orthodox who are the
majority of christians
uh i proved that the majority of
christians don't
approve of the protestant they consider
them as hawari
they don't consider him as true
christian yeah they believe
in also the mother of god mary
i said they were they found the father
they found the son
and the one who goes between them they
had to have the mother
it's the holy family they wanted the
holy family
i mean how is she the mother of god what
does she do
is she a god then because one christian
was saying
that people worship mary i said yes they
do
most christians the worshiper the
invoker the catholics
yeah yeah and the orthodox don't forget
they're about 80
of christians the orthodox uh christians
yeah like from serbia
from this part of the world russia
russia serbia the coptics yeah the
coptics are orthodox too
they don't agree with the catholics the
different religions but in general
catholics and tri and orthodox are
similar in so many ways
now the protestants now are the ones who
came up with the idea we shouldn't have
idols
statues or worship images or whatever
but they worship
mary they invoke her i have an article
here
fifty righteous concepts brought by
muhammad allah that
i said this is a clear example
for christianity and i mean the catholic
church i'm not talking about the
you know the citizens you know how
don't becomes do so they start with
don't worship images they say
this is uh how they interpret it is that
worshiping images as a way of adoration
to a door it's not like worshiping the
image by
thinking that actually the person is the
creator
what's the difference when you adore
somebody
you adore them for what for qualities
that they don't
deserve by elevating them to the status
that is not a human being
so jesus he was a human being they made
him a god
made his mother a god so when they adore
them and adore their pictures
they're worshipping them because worship
is not only restricted
to your thinking that he is god i'll
give you a clear example the time of
prophet muhammed
either worshipers of his people quraish
in mecca they worship worshipping idols
they did not worship them because they
created them
because allah says to him in the quran
which is the muslim holy book
if you ask them those idol worshipers
who created the heavens and the earth
they will say allah
then why are you worshiping they say
these are intermediaries between us
because they're good with allah allah
likes them that's the same reason they
go and confess their sins
to the priest a sinner himself because
everybody sins
and i don't mean i don't mean that the
catholics by priests by themselves they
are
sinners everybody sins you know they go
to a sinner
to absolve them with their sin as an
intermediary in islam
even if you didn't do good in your
religion
for 50 years 60 years 70 years
80 years then you remember
i didn't do good i didn't obey my lord
say allah no no intermediary just
just call upon the creator listen to you
and hear you yeah
you would actually we're almost out of
time but tell us you would actually fit
the description of
someone living during the time of jesus
uh would you say that people
in that type part of the world with the
beard with the
you know the almost like the sermon of
the mount right
he was wearing the thobe i was
once given a lecture at the university
of austin
so we had people came and the professors
and we had a large crowd
we had a group of 60 70 african-american
muslims
came one and thought they looked very
beautiful and i told the people i didn't
fail said look at how beautiful these
waters are
they used to be christianity whatever it
is look at them they're all one one
ummah they're coming to listen to me um
so i said to one woman stood up and said
uh jesus is love jesus is this and that
why are these women covered they were
wearing the hijab covered you know some
of them covering the faces
i didn't know how she jumped from
jesus's love
i have no idea what happened in between
i said listen
uh first of all uh
if you think about jesus as being loved
we agree with that
he was a loving person however if you go
to a christian store
and by what they claim is the picture of
mary
you will find they're covered like these
sisters not like you in hijab
yeah yeah she's covered except for the
face and hands right very important yeah
people if you also buy a picture for
jesus
and look at me you will find that we're
similar except for the glasses
and they all started laughing i said you
know take your glasses i look like jesus
same color skin from the same area of
the world
same area also right i belong to the
prophet family this is the first time i
ever say that to anybody in public
so i'm a cousin of asia himself myself
you got the lineage connecting all the
way back
yes ma so i am and i'm wearing and he's
going to be wearing a soap like this one
and having a beard
she didn't see anything i said look at
isa your own pictures yet you have for
jesus he looks like
me mary she looks like this and i said
like this you know without the glasses
but of course he came from our area of
the world
europeans have nothing to do with jesus
he wasn't sent to them
the new testament said the statement
that i'm sure you heard it
muslims heard it hindus whoever reads
anything about the bible one of the most
significant
verses that he keeps saying i was only
sent to the lost house
to the last sheep of the house of israel
europeans at the house of israel
he says how can i how can i
i should say it in arabic maybe he says
ayah was only
sent to the lost sheep of the house
of israel the africans don't fit there
the arabs don't fit there he wasn't sent
to the arabs even
the europeans don't fit there how they
claim to be followers of jesus
and distort his message he never once
said
people i created you i am god
the holy ghost is god worship me he
never said that
never i have 19 in this book here
and the second and first jihad book i
have 19
references from major uh
catholic books encyclopedias major
scholars
they all agree trinity is not
in the bible period read it
now i want to take the next few minutes
that we have to talk about
some of your books so people can
actually this is very powerful here the
rights and um and humane
concepts so righteous and humane concept
brought by
prophet muhammad peace and blessings be
upon it because many people as soon as
you say prophet muhammad
the smart people who have investigated
they were genuine they really want to
know the truth
they love the pure monotheism that was
brought by all the messengers
absolutely you know and and the prophet
muhammad was no exception he was just
the last and final messenger and then
when you give this powerful verse people
they're like hold on
uh he was only sent for for that uh
group of people who want to stray
from the way prophet muhammad he's until
the last day
and there's concepts you there's i'm
sure
um even more than 50 you probably just
touched upon 50
and they're in this book people want to
know more about prophet muhammad they
can get this book here
uh prophet muhammad's role in islam and
then you have a holy word crusade
and jihad tell us where people can
support your work and uh get some of get
some of your material to learn more
currently i'm uh i'm visiting i live
half of the time in jordan by the way
when i work in my books i stay
there because i can't concentrate on
here people keep calling me class
lecture here i can't concentrate and so
i'm trying to uh
uh this is the third edition uh
inshallah that's coming from these books
i reviewed them if they're ready
yes i would like to have this available
for everybody but at the moment
they're out to print and it's going to
be a major
advantage inshallah for us for islam
especially when you read this
and give it to some non-muslims you know
this one explains islam
the pillars of islam and the pillars of
the islamic faith
in 100 pages so i'm up to print for
these two
and i would welcome any kind of uh
help and support for that because uh i
am one man i can do everything yeah
but i am so dedicated to this these two
books and the jihad book
because the jihad book now the biggest
problem oh you said you said a word now
you know some people are getting you
know a little bit nervous you said you
had
yeah i my articles i say a call to jihad
too
yeah but you when you read inside uh
like one article i'm sorry
i have to say it i wanted to give to a
seminar
yeah in the university of virginia just
uh two years ago
the topic was about jihad so they said
no yes no yes yes
okay now when i when i said this
i wrote an article at the same time are
you thinking of buying
a slave girl from isis that's the
article okay
so they go and take some muslims
did not want me to talk about jihad
because they're harboring some
ideas of the isis you know they don't
want me because you know
i can talk well alhamdulillah you know i
studied english literature in britain i
my arab is much better than my english
and i'm well acquainted with what i'm
writing
and i'm not a scholar i'm a scholar i'm
a student of knowledge i love to be that
way until the day i die
keep learning so they went and gave to
the university this article
they thought that the people are stupid
like them and when the
lady read the article it says wait a
minute
this guy says this is not islamic
this is rape and he brings statements
from scholars of today
that this is a major sin and they should
be stoned for it
but he gave it the idol to this to the
lady to think that ah this guy shouldn't
be talking he's going to be selling
slaves
oh because the title now it was a
tequila to bring people in
and they try to use that against you
yeah i use like this 50.
my son-in-law started i think he
designed my books
he started this big i said make it
bigger bigger bigger because when you
see it from far
yeah you're going to be attracted to the
number here and come and see what's 50
what
yeah it's a way of attracting people yes
but jihad of course i say it all the
time uh
and i keep repeating it now i keep
repeating it but it's the way muhammad
salla
the one that led to the successes of the
islamic
state in the beginning to this to make
it
islam and muslims the superpower of the
world
for centuries the islamic civilization
all the knowledge
christians and jews lived in those
countries all the way
until isis came in peace they prospered
nobody bothered them
in fact a part of jihad i want you to
remember this
a part of jihad is that muslims fight
to protect christians and jews who live
under their control
muslims will never allow anybody from
outside to come and attack
christians to harm the jews that's a
part of that's part of the struggle
yeah yeah what is that word for some
people that hearing it for the first
time and they got the you know
uh uh obviously does not mean holy war
absolutely absolutely not so what is
what does it mean in english how do you
translate jihad in english
before we leave um is it struggle to
strive
how do you that's the comment you had
like we spoke about
elohim you know different ways of saying
the same basically the same word
elohim allah is the same word yeah
yahweh
even is so close to the
jihad comes from the root word of jud
three letters it means to pay the effort
now what kind of effort it's it varies
now
imam ibn khayim al-jaziyyah who wrote
the mad
which i'm translating and i put his
definition of jihad here
and the first and second edition of the
jihad book
second edition of the jihad book is
sitting on my laptop there
yeah i can't print it
i really love for muslims to read it i
have information there
about isis that i added and all that
stuff
so juhad means to pay this the effort
now imam mulcahy said there are 13
different kinds of jihad
one of them only is to fight the enemies
of islam aggressors
in the battlefield on the battlefield
just one of them
what are the others you have to struggle
against the temptations of
shaytan the devil you have to fight
against your own desires
to live the comfort uh to cheat people
to mistreat them to abuse them
to not abuse them to not cheat them to
fight against that yeah
like that like that's prevalent today
people are cheating abusing all over the
place
so apart you know you you fight the
devil
and his temptations and ideas and doubts
about the religion
that he brings into our minds his
temptations wants to lead us to
be going astray temptations have to do
with our desires
we have to control our desires so that
we don't
anger allah or you know across his
limits
you have also to convey the message
to the people it's a part of jihad
conveying the truth yes
one of the four islamic law
you know most popular islamic law uh
teachers of all time
he's from the fourth century of islam a
major scholar of islam
he said anyone who defends the religion
by word of writing he's a mujahid he
does jihad
so jihad is me writing these books
because i could work with my degrees in
english or other you know i could work i
put them aside more than 34 years ago
and i said
this is what i want to do i am in a
unique position to transfer islamic
knowledge is here because of my
knowledge in arabi
is even more more powerful and stronger
than my knowledge in english i'm i'm
suited to transfer this is what i do
this is jihad
yeah i'll tell you something else when i
came here today it was raining
i started two hours before the time you
told me to come and you came late
i'm joking that was it you had
i paid the effort man it was raining i
could have said man i'm not familiar
with chicago i'm going to stay
no no i came here because i'd like to
see you every time you're my brother and
i love you very much for what you do
too also this is a struggle we have to
do
so this is jihad in fact and i'll end
with this the
women during the time of muhammad salla
the prophet to allah
last and final messenger of allah and
prophets who came with the same
monotheism message every prophet came
with including jesus
so the woman asked him said what kind of
jihad can we do or can we do jihad like
men do
he said hajj
is a good way of jihad pilgrimage so
when women go
to that because it's not easy you know
you do the acts of hajj
over a few days you know you have to go
around the kaaba whatever praying
you know next to the kaaba which is uh
it's not here the kaaba is the house of
allah
in mecca and this is house number one
for us with regards to being sacred
so rasulullah said hajj is a good jihad
for you
so i said to some people and the same
i think austin i said if jihad means
holy war
then what are women going to do to hajj
to kill themselves or what
what are they going to do they're
praying they're they're going round the
counter they didn't do
violence they don't kill anybody in fact
the jihad itself because of 13 meanings
only one
about fighting just one actual fighting
it means that when i say i made jihad it
means i killed somebody on the way here
i didn't kill anybody i'm a very safe
driver
and i care about people i don't drive
behind old people
very closely because i think it's
islamically
not allowed i don't drive too fast
because allah
islam doesn't allow me so the jihad that
i made to come here
it was in holy war let me end with this
holy war in arabi would be jihad
see well i'll finish with this inshallah
holy war if you translate it to arabia
it's going to be holy mukha
as we said with regards to the words i
repeat again
elohim allah god doesn't belong
this garbage from holy war
islam jihad muslim
muslim what's a muslim i have i have
never met a muslim in my life
why don't you respect us we are larger
than you
in this life and islam is going forward
we have seen it in our lifetime
what the promise allah gave to muhammad
the prophecy
that before the end of time islam will
enter every house on this earth
we've seen it so take us seriously
because
by allah we will never give up
struggling for our religion
you want to use the word jihad for it
because it is the word you had for it
for every kind of jihad but only
according
to the successful way and the blessed
way that prophet muhammad and his
companions and the
islamic nation did all the way until the
qaeda came
that's why i have no sympathy with
al-qaeda
or their ideas or practices or their
leaders they messed up my religion and
eurozone
they made people suspect us if they see
somebody like you
they're going to be thinking like what
this guy did in san bernardino
he's working with in the office with the
people for years
they trusted him he goes and takes a gun
and kills them
they're not worth a spit and i'm sorry
to say that because they tarnished my
religion and yours
and left a baby to be raised
in a cafe country would they wanted to
fight
the non-muslims because their kuffar
kafir or you know
but they left their child to be raised
in the same environment they wanted to
fight
what kind of nonsense why didn't you
stay in this life
and don't let people be deceived for
years that you're a good guy
he's polite he's nice he comes in time
he
wha what why why did you do that for
what reason
not for my religion i can tell you
because
one of the worst things that the
khawaris do and one of the things that
islam wants the gates considers it a
major sin
if people think that you're okay that
they're safe from you
and you betray them deception that's not
allowed
absolutely yeah thank you thank you so
much for your time now tell me
uh how can people get a hold of you to
to help out with uh your work and
uh since inshaallah is going to be
coming islamlife.com
uh wait for that but primarily for now
uh my my email address i mean
uh uh christian's target
and i have proof for that actually we're
gonna go to the authorities these are
probably probably some extreme elements
yeah of course yeah yeah i'm talking
always when i say christians i mean
the ones that other christians even
don't like because there are so many
decent people in christianity and today
sympathetic to muslims
in fact i think most christians in
america sympathize with us they don't
like this oppression or anything yeah
but the always you find extremist like
the man who just killed 17 uh
you can say these uh the kk type the
neo-nazi type the
you know the far right that they call
them white supremacy groups
but he's not a terrorist you know that's
an important point and the one in las
vegas
is not a terrorist because what's the
opposite of
but he is a terrorist he terrorized
people i know but what's the opposite of
terrorism
feeling good happy safe huh so i wrote
an article
is it terrorism or he's telling people
listen guys i'm gonna kill you
but be happy i'm not a muslim it's not a
jihad it's not terrorism
feel good or to go to the families and
say your son was killed today
by the way it wasn't terrorism and [ __ ]
say oh hallelujah
nothing there is no difference between
somebody
who is a muslim doing it thinking in
allah's name
that in islam's name and somebody who
did what they did
in in connecticut in that school in las
vegas
this is like the white american version
of isis
they're christians yeah yeah right you
see i want to clarify again because i
when i talk about christians i don't
mean the whole majority of them
because arab christians for example
sympathize with with muslims a lot
especially
about palestine i'm talking about the
hawaii sects that they have they do have
khawarij
these islamophobe absolutely but they
don't call them terrorist terrorists
it's only about a muslim so if a muslim
is caught
planning something he didn't kill
anybody but
he was been in touch with isis they call
him a terrorist
this guy kids kills 58 people in las
vegas vegas but he's not a terrorist
he killed 59 because you can't kill
yourself
this is another issue we can talk about
later suicide
in islam is a major sin that takes one
out of islam
how can one commit suicide in the name
of islam
and call it jihad so how you can reach
me
uh my email address is the best
way you can reach me if you want to
support i can communicate
through that islam life gmail.com
i-s-l-a-m-l-i-f like frank
e gmail.com islam life gmail.com
i will i would love to see these books
inshaallah
in the third edition and the jihad book
second edition i love to see them
very very soon so if anyone is
interested to help
uh i'll be grateful and uh the last word
i've given the jihad book to so many fbi
agents
and they really appreciate it i had a
meeting with three fbi agents in the dc
nice people and i i felt from my heart
they're sincere
they don't they don't take this as a as
a
war against islam or against any islamic
you know just
a group of uh criminals a gang for
you know and one of the guys who read my
book before
i gave them i think another copy he said
to the others too
read this book read it and he was asking
me what about the second edition
because when people hear what islam says
and my way is
put a word here reference here
you have about 180 references here
you know i don't see anything without
proof bringing the proof
from our religion from our prophets
our scholars al-baghdadi of isis
is not of our scholars osama bin laden
according to one of the major scholars
of our time ibn baz
he called him khawariji so for muslims
who don't like what i'm saying now
get over it i'm going to keep saying to
allah
and i have never been a coward in my
life again because muslims need to know
this too
so that they are not deceived by the by
the propaganda
non-muslims need to do it because this
is the type of jihad that i can do
well thank you so much for being with us
thank you and thank you for tuning in we
learned a lot
you see what happens to the son comes to
his father and gives him this
crazy news that has nothing to do with
islam
so we dispel that myth separating islam
from isis isis has nothing to do with
islam
called it insane state the crazy uh
things that are going on there has
nothing to do with islam we learned
about
jesus we learned about so many different
topics here at the last in final message
of mohammed peace and blessed be upon
them
you got informed you got informed you
continue to
tune in and you'll learn more and if you
have any other questions you can call us
1-800-662-islam we'll see you next time
until then
subscribe if you haven't already peace
be with you assalamu